hey friends looking for a challenge with
your PO well this is the one that has
kept me going for the past few months
and I'd like to share it with
you Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body and
brain and today I'm breaking down a PO
move I have been playing with for
several months now that I'm calling a g
snatch but before we dive in I want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk flow
fests flow toys pirat light toys and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these amazing companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca Becken thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission so it has been a
long long time since I have uploaded any
videos on py Trix that I have been
playing around with that would be
considered new or even newish and quite
frankly this one still probably wouldn't
be considered new I first started
playing around with this idea in a tech
blog that dates way back to 2013 but it
wasn't until recently that I really
started practicing it in Earnest as its
own unique kind of movement so the
essential idea here is that we're taking
the POI as it is say stalled in any
particular direction in and boom we are
just kind of snapping on the tether a
little bit to pull it around back
towards our hand and catching it when
that happens now the thing is this
actually reminds me quite a bit of a
trick from back in the day that we used
to call a GP where you snap the tether
in order to get the poy to move back and
forth between different positions
usually up and down and because of that
I have been referring to it as a g
snatch in my head now please note there
other people playing around with this
trick out there and I have no idea what
they may call it but for the purposes of
this video I'm calling it a g snatch and
if consensus arrives around calling it
something different it'll be down in the
comments beneath this video in the
future but I did want to break down for
you all kind of the basics of how this
trick works as well as how I have been
drilling it because I've been having a
lot of fun with it so to get down some
of the basics let's just start off with
a pendulum going back and forth from
side to side of our hand and at either
side here I can kind of Yank on the
tether right quick to send the poy head
careening across a horizontal line
please note I do not want this to be a
point where I'm just doing a pendulum my
hand is raising up above and then uh
dropping back down I really truly want
the PO to go across the same horizontal
line that my hand is and this will be
important in just a second all right so
if you've gotten to a point where you
feel pretty comfortable just kind of
snapping that PO head back and forth
across you like so then it's time to
start working on the actual catch itself
all right so to make this work we got to
talk about grip the first thing to
understand is that whenever I'm doing
this snap and going to a catch I am kind
of pinching the handle uh in this little
shape that I'm creating by hooking my
index finger around and pushing it
tightly against the palm of my hand that
way I have my other three fingers as
well as my thumb available to do the
catch like so once I've made the catch
I'm still holding on to that handle
uh with that little Crook in my index
finger but I'm mainly gripping the PO
between my thumb in Pinky and depending
upon the dexterity of your hand you
might be able to bring in additional
fingers fairly easily but this is where
the bulk of my grip strength comes from
and of course once you've done the catch
you can push the PO right back out again
like so so we catch with our thumb and
Pinky and we toss the poy back out we
can also do this when we're say stalling
down
or stalling up in both of these cases
I'm really thinking that I'm yanking on
the tether even with the up stall yes I
know that technically speaking I could
just leave my hand there to catch the
poy as it's falling back down but the
effect that I really want here is to
really almost seem like a yo-yo getting
pulled back into my palm like so so
basically I count four specific ways
that this can be done namely uh it can
be done off to the non-native side it
can be done off to the native side it
can be done from a down stall it can be
done from an up stall like so and that
also means that we can drill this in a
systematized fashion so say I can start
off with my pois spinning in together
same do stalls up and then catch and
then release and switch back to the
other side of my body boom and make
catches there in fact I can just
essentially use some tuck turns to send
the poy back and forth across my body
catch them on either side and by the
same token I can do this off of down
stalls going to either side of my body
either taking tuck turns up and around
my shoulders or just a little flower
petal up top but either way I can get in
a series of reps with these down stalls
and making the catches happen for the
ones out to the side it's a little bit
harder and quite frankly I'm just
usually doing these off of pendulums
letting the PO go out to the sides and
then pulling the back to catch them like
so and this also means that we can do
the same drill in other timing and
Direction modes like say together
opposites where once again I can do
these stalls and catches on the outside
as well as the inside getting both my
Center Line as well as my peripheral and
of course I can do the same thing with
the down stalls pulling up on the inside
pulling up on the outside getting the
outside and the inside ones are a little
bit more challenging what I've been
finding is I want to start with a
butterfly and then just do pendulums and
catch them as they come in and then go
across boom and catch them as they go
back across and again we want to do
several reps of this going back and
forth when we get to split timings it
basically rules out the pieces to the
sides simply because coming out of a
stall versus out of a pendulum you wind
up with slightly different momentum
characteristics on the two po so say if
I want to go out to the side like that
or like that it gets a little crazy it
is possible but it gets a little crazy
so in the meantime what I've been doing
to get more consistent work on this is
to do up and down together like so first
with my right hand always doing the down
stalls and then with my left hand always
doing the down stalls like
so and then that takes us to split Time
same direction which combines together
all of the most obnoxious elements of
both together opposite as well as split
time opposites wherein both we have to
do both an up and a down at the same
time as well as do the ones on the
periphery of our vision too so once
again here there's right always going up
and left always going down and of course
the version where it's always left going
up and right going down so this gives
you a good framework to begin practicing
these and getting accustomed to them in
all the different timing and Direction
modes but there's also another version
of this that I think is really fun that
kind of inverts the physics of uh this
first version of the G snatches so
basically instead of doing the snap and
bringing the poad to my hand I can
instead bring my hand out to the PO head
like so this has this really nice kind
of arresting effect to it essentially
where we find that things are just kind
of Frozen in midair and of course the
flip side to this is that we want to
kind of release the tether back out as
though it were always kind of hanging
there to begin with and truth be told I
think that this creates some pretty
marvelous effects when the two of them
are used together and of course the
obvious question why have I been playing
around with these so much lately and the
answer to that is they actually make for
a fantastic addition to my style of Po
dance I can be using these boom as a way
to engage in suspensions which have long
been a bug bear for me when it comes to
PO spinning they are a way that I can
easily stop the POI from moving when my
body does and take a moment to
say strike a pose so there you go g
snatches do you play around with these
too let me know down in the comments and
yeah also let me know if there's another
name for these that I am not aware of
please be sure to like comment share and
subscribe to help other people find this
video and of course to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all rock thank you so
much and if you out there watching are
not currently a supporter but you'd like
to become one you can do that by signing
up on patreon over at
patreon.com drexfactor poy there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better than that you'll
be able to help me out in my mission to
bring po spinning and flow Arts to the
whole wide world so go check that out
please and thank you and if you'd like
to learn about some other methods that I
use for doing suspensions with po I did
a video on all the methods that I had
access to a couple years ago I will go
ahead and link to that down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace